and speaking of iconic movies last
night's london premiere i know tony
you're excited we're all excited
everybody's excited about it
top gun maverick had a royal drop in the
duke and duchess of cambridge joined tom
cruise on the red carpet apparently
prince william is a fan of the 1986
original and cruz invited him to swing
by william and kate mingled with the top
gun cast including jennifer connolly and
miles teller who plays the son of
maverick's friend goose
the prince even had some pretty fly
loafers literally they had pictures of
f-18s on them
i guess he was really into the top gun
fashion theme remember he was a royal
air force helicopter pilot top gun
maverick is distributed by paramount
pictures owned by our our parent company
thank them all uh paramount club it is
such a good movie we all saw it you are
really in love with what we all are come
on it's a fantastic it is we're not just
saying it because it's a paramount move
it's the type of thing that you have to
see it on the big screen yeah you don't
watch it the whole family don't watch it
or get the heart pumping it's so
paramount you did it tom cruise is back
as as we said popcorn movies are back
that's right
thank you so much